I feel lost lost Jason Momoa 'he's
reaction to the Game of Thrones series
finale is hashtag relatable after eight
seasons the hit HBO show has officially
ended and while the final episode left
some fans a little disappointed
no one has summed up the Internet's
feelings quite like Jason you punk
the 39 year old who starred on the show
in season 1 and has remained a loyal fan
ever since took to Instagram to
livestream his reaction to some of the
biggest moments in the series finale
Khaleesi I love you familia I love you
so sorry I wasn't there for you Jason
gave a quick shout-out to his queen
emilia clarke and the creators who cast
him as called Drogo i just want to say
thank you to David dan and the whole
crew I wouldn't be here today if it
wasn't for David and Dan who made drug
on I was very honored to be a part of
the show and I can't believe it's the
last episode and if you're wondering how
Jason felt about Danny's villainous turn
he was all for it when I was a girl my
brother told me it was made with a
thousand souls from Aegon's fallen
enemies what do a thousand swords look
like in the mind of a little girl who
can't count to 20
I imagined a mountain of swords too high
to climb so many fallen enemies you
could only see the source of a khan's
feet and just look at the heartbreak in
his eyes as he watched Drogo nudge
Danny's dead body
Jason was also not thrilled when he
learned that bran was the one ruling
Westeros at the end who better to lead
us into the future who gives up who
gives up and then when Jon Snow was
pardoned and sent back to the Nights
Watch Jason was a mood learning that his
queen was getting zero justice let me
get this straight
no one is very happy which means it's
good compromise I suppose you're going
back to what you did in the first place
oh my god he was with the actor at the
season 8 premiere in New York City in
April where his goodbyes to the show
really started we've been missing you on
Game of Thrones since very early on but
you still always come back you've
supported this cast what does it mean
for you to be here tonight on the final
season premiere Simona I mean I love
Dave and Dan that's really Dave and Dan
and Amelia kid closest to so it's just
yeah it's a beautiful thing to be a part
of the show your typical Game of Thrones
watch party night like how do you guys
watch it on a couch like how do you guys
prepare for it together honey well it
depends where we are in the world if
we're at a place that isn't ours maybe
real television and there's usually like
some nice lighting and oh going on
[Music]